في اليوم الرابع من منافسات بطوله كاس
العالم المقامه في الدوحه اذا كان يمكن
استخلاص درس فسيكون بالتاكيد انه على
المنتخبات الكبيره ان تحذر من منتخبات
اسيا فيبدو انها لم تاتي للتنزهه بعد
الاجازه الكبير الذي حققه المنتخب السعودي
بالامس وبعد انتصاره على الارجنتين بهدفين
مقابل هدف في واحده من اكبر مفاجات
البطوله كررت اليابان المفاجاه اليوم بعد
ان الحقت الهزيمه بالمنتخب الالماني
بهدفين مقابله هدف ايضا واعادت للمشجعين
الالمان ذكريات اليمه في عام 2018 كان
خروجه المانيا من دوري المجموعات في
البطوله على يد فريق اسيوي اخر هو كوريا
الجنوبيه منتخب المانيا المنتخب بالجراح
الاسيويه اصبح في وضع صعب في مجموعه صعبها
على نفسه فمن المقرر ان يلتقي الاحد
المقبل بمنتخب اسبانيا الذي افترسي
كوستاريكا بسبعه اهداف لا شيء وتحتاج
المانيا للفوز على اسبانيا لتعزيز حدودها
هذا جانب من مباريات اليوم اما جانب اخر
فهو ايجابي بالنسبه لنا كعرب وهو تبادل
التعادل منتخب المغرب السلبي مع وصيف بطل
النسخه الماضيه كرواتيا الامر الذي يجعل
حظوظ المغرب افضل في مجموعته التي تضم
ايضا بلجيكا وكندا